I want to wear things that make me feel  good about myself and still feel sexy  well this look is definitely making us  see sexy Kim Kardashian turned heads in  a skin-tight yellow vintage Versace  dress on Wednesday in Miami nothing like  the oh she Miami crowed eyes  Kim stepped out for a night on the town  with her besties Larsa Pippen and  Jonathan Cheban good feeling good and  looking great for dinner in typical Kim  fashion she left little to the  imagination in an eye-popping mini  trendy clear sandals and a sleek high  ponytail to complete her look before  catching up with friends Kim was on mom  duty she shared the cutest video of her  and Kanye's son st. having his own day  party at lunch  [Music]  [Applause]